- Welcome back to part two
of reacting to my old videos.
Today we're going to focus mostly
on some music videos.
- [Jenna] Oh n- n- n- n- n- no.
- These are super, super embarassing.
I mean, you know, I love music.
I feel like the problem
with a lot of these is,
there's a lot of things.
We would record these and make the lyrics,
everything the night
before in Garage Band,
and then film it in a day the next day.
- We would have a really
good time doing this though.
- We had so much fun.
- I don't even know how it happened,
we'd be out and about and then
(gasps)
we have a great idea for a video.
And then we'd drop whatever we were doing
the rest of the day,
go home, plan it, go to the costume store.
We would have our little
notepad with lyrics.
We would listen to the original
song hundreds of times.
- Well...
- Oh no, you gotta do Harris Theater.
- This one, specifically.
- You gotta do,
Harris-
- Wait till you see this one.
This was an original.
This wasn't even a cover, 2010.
- When we would go to
the beach on vacation,
I never wanted to go to
Harris Theater, anymore.
- Okay, so every year my family and
I would go on vacation
to North Carolina...
- You look better.
- Yeah. I was getting there.
And my brows are in.
- Brows are fillin' in.
- Hello there, kids. What
are you doin' over there?
Do you remember this?
- You made this, right?
- Yes.
Come on.
- Yeah. I was pushing you in
the cart and filming, I think.
♪ I laced up my shoes. ♪
♪ I got a wad of cash, and
a sexy fake mustache. ♪
- Didn't have enough
time to find a mustache.
♪ I'm at the sea. ♪
Wait till you see it.
♪ Look who I see. ♪
♪ Oh. Fancy seein' you here. ♪
♪ What are you doing at the T? ♪
♪ Oh I'm just gettin' a gallon o' milk. ♪
♪ So I go... ♪
- That's me.
I looked okay.
- I got my milk.
- Why are we so tan?
- 'Cause we're at the beach.
- That makes sense.
- There's also a tan setting
on the camera. They used to -
- I remember that!
Did it make your hair yellow, too?
- No. That's my body.
- Oh my god, the beef.
♪ Sail to the day... ♪
♪ So, did you get that gallon
o' milk you were lookin' for? ♪
I remember that tank top.
I really liked that tank top at the time.
- Mine?
- No. Mine.
Why would I like your -
- I like mine.
- Cookies.
- Where's Bree? Let's see, Bree.
Oh my god, I'm pushing you in a -
- Cat fi- Oh my god,
I'm in a chair
- In a child's cart.
It's not even adult.
- What is happening?
I'm wearing shorts!
- Shorts?!
- I don't ever wear shorts.
- Wait a minute.
- And I love shoes on.
- Well, that's gross.
Every time I -
- Wait, I'm not wearing shoes?
Why was I not wearing
shoes in a grocery store?
- I dunno, but every time
I see you wear shorts,
I think of The Price is Right,
and I think when can we go back
'cause the ten years is almost up.
(gasp)
You filmed this in like
a studio apartment.
So, it's not like a nice studio.
- No, that was my one-bedroom.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- This is one-bedroom?
What am I wearing?
- That's back in style now.
Like a romper.
Is that what the kids are calling it?
- I'm not sure.
- A romper?
- It looks like I'm uh
Clearly, I'm not well.
- This was 2009.
(gasp)
♪ ...little turn. ♪
♪ Dance and dance and move like this. ♪
♪ You don't even know the - ♪
- You know I feel a little less bad about
you making my voice in the hair video
that you did.
- Oo oo hoo.
Oh my god.
- How do you feel that
this is four million views?
Four million people have seen this.
You should hide.
You should duck now.
You should
You should make yourself
not be seen anymore.
Stay down there.
Here's the thing.
You filmed this- was this the IKEA green?
- Yeah. It was an IKEA blanket.
- Green IKEA blanket.
She used as a green screen.
She hung -
- A little tiny camera.
- Like a little point'n'shoot.
- I think we went to Forever 21
to try to find you this outfit.
- We did. Yeah.
(laughs)
- You're wearing shorts again.
Could you imagine... Oh my god.
- Could you imagine posting this now?
Well, I technically am
posting it because -
- Whoa! Oh no!
- Oh my gosh.
Kesha.
- Someone just discovered hairspray.
- I was trying to be Kesha.
There is an app for that.
♪ I got a pedicure for my toes. ♪
(mumbles)
- Did you actually get that or is that-
- No, I got it.
You guys knew where I filmed this at.
(laughs)
- Where did you film it?
- Somewhere.
- I liked it where you filmed it.
- I'll tell you off camera.
- I like off-camera secrets.
(pop music)
♪ Tonite. ♪
- So, how long do you
think this took you to-
You really in a bra?!
Is that a see-through?
This is
spicy!
- Oh my gosh!
- This is super spicy!
- Super spicy.
- Spicy.
- I remember -
- Whoa!
- Scandal.
- Do you think this is why
your channel is restricted
from that secret show?
- Maybe.
Ooh la la!
- My goodness!
This is too scandalous for my eyes.
My eyes!
- Super scandal.
Next.
- No. We're out.
- Ooh. This was 2010.
- You should've known better by then.
(Jen raspberries)
I can't speak because
I'm scared.
- I feel ill.
- Me too.
I don't know if it's
the coffee or my site.
Did you not believe in
capitalizing letters or what's up?
- I don't know.
- There's not--
You capitalized "You're" and "Kesha"
(laughing)
- This is so bad.
- This is pretty bad.
- Okay.
- Four million views!
- This is my most viewed video.
And I just wanna say--
- 3M was the inspiration.
- The Will.i.am had seen this video.
- He hadn't?
- And I apolo--
- He had seen--
- N-n-no, he had seen it.
And I apologized to him for it.
- Did he just, was he disliking it?
♪ Feeling ♪
- Wow. You were super glossy.
♪ Oo oo. ♪
- I remember that outfit.
♪ ...be a prof-a-pick ♪
- Did you still have that pink?
- I don't.
I wish I did.
I love it.
- You were so glossy.
- Hey, do you know what tonight is?
- Friday.
- It's the night.
- 'Cause I think it's Friday.
- No, tonight's the night.
We'll pick it up.
- No, I thought you click it up.
- No, can you--
♪ Fro-Fro-Pink ♪
- Look at that necklace.
I wore that.
♪ 'Night's the night. ♪
♪ We'll pick it up. ♪
- Oh, okay.
♪ I got my camera. ♪
Let's snap it up.
- Snap it up.
♪ Turn on the flash. ♪
♪ And oh my god. ♪
- No one uses the flash anymore.
♪ Let's keep it moving. ♪
- You used that scene in the
previous thing with the mouth
and the foam
- Yeah
because each one of those
backgrounds were 25 to 45 dollars.
- Whoa! You were big-ballin'
- That was all--
and-I-and-I
I didn't have much money.
- I cannot--
- My memory card was full.
- Believe the things that my eyes
(sigh)
are reliving.
♪ Tonight's gonna be a... ♪
- Look at the old Facebook.
Look at these tags.
Oh my goodness.
- Man.
- Saved everything.
It gets better. Hashtag.
- Oo.
Oh I thought you mean this.
- Oh no, it can't get any worse.
- I think we've peaked.
- This was the,
this actually looks very good.
- 2012.
- Ed still has all those Legos.
- He does.
- I just need Lego pieces.
That arm?
You see that?
You know that's my fault, right?
- I do.
- I was changing
and then I thought someone
was coming in the door,
so I hurried up to like
to put my shirt on.
- Oh. Did you get scared?
- I got scared.
Knocked over the whole arm,
and I was just like (gasp)
'Cause Ed just spent like
how long making that?
- Yeah. But look how cool.
♪ Back together... ♪
Ed.
Aagh!
That's Ed.
- I was like who is that?
That's Ed Palumbo?
- That's our buddy, Ed!
Oh my god!
- That's my tall buddy.
That's cool.
- Oh yes.
- That's Ed.
- Joe shot this for me.
- Can you,
look your hair's a nice
color and everything.
- I like that color.
- Very nice color.
- It's about the same as it is now.
It's a little lighter note.
- I cannot.
Let's react to DotEd from 2012.
- Oh my gosh.
- That's insane.
That is
absolutely
insane
♪ This time, I'm telling
you, I'm telling you. ♪
Oh god.
- What is that mask?
What is wrong with us?
I remember I saw my friend from home
when we were filming this.
We saw so many people.
- So many people.
- That we knew this day.
- Nathan?
Did we meet Nathan in this one?
It was another shoot I think
We did see a lot of people.
- I think, I think it was.
- Oh my own-
I still have-
that's what I have my TV on now.
I like that necklace.
I wonder where that's at.
- It's a nice necklace.
- It's Tiffany's.
Nice hair.
Nice hair length.
Okay. I remember this.
That's me!
That's Jenna!
- That's you!
That's you!
Look at you laughing!
(Jenna laughs)
Look, pry cacklan.
- Wow.
You really made me work for that, huh?
You were like "Sit back
here" and you laugh.
You laugh and you sell it.
- You laugh a lot.
- Oh my god. Wait.
There's another one.
It's Taylor Swift.
(typing)
Well, let's spell it right.
(snorts)
This is it.
This is where we met Nathan.
- This is where we met Nathan.
- Nathan shoots a bunch
of my videos for me now.
And a lot of the cooking ones.
- It's 2010.
- And 2010. We met him on the street,
and he said, "Hey, I shoot videos."
So, I was like--
- Well alright, well
- Cool stranger danger.
- We're making stranger danger.
I remember that dress as well. I hated it.
♪ ...had to wear an ugly, dirty dress... ♪
If you bring out that pink guitar,
I swear I'm going to hit you with it.
Do not bring out a pink guitar.
I'll hit you.
- This is so great.
It's got this card.
It's got a good color.
- Yeah.
(guitar strum)
- Look at me!
- You're wearing tank tops again.
- Why did I wear so many tank tops?
- You're like, "I'm
gonna get into tanktops
"this year, 2010," you're in tank tops.
- Oh my gosh.
This is out of tune.
- You know what's gonna be crazy.
Seven years from...
I remember that!
You were like "Jenny, you
keep on, go back there,
"and you spin."
- Look. I never even took this off.
- Is it suppose to come off?
Seven years from now, we're gonna be like,
why was that girl wearing a, uh, hole?
Why did she have holes in her shirt?
Why was she doing the
things she was doing?
- Hole.
- I can't believe she wore
yoga pants all the time.
What kind of pant,
what are the pants in
the future gonna be like?
- The future pants.
What? I was doing my laundry outside.
What are the future pants gonna be?
What am I gonna be
wearing in ten more years?
- I think we need to create future pants.
- Future pants.
I love it.
- I swear. Don't create future pants.
- Nope. Already patented.
- This is my thing.
It's already mine.
- Mmmnh.
- Mmmnh. Love. Future pants.
- What was this trash?
Hey you were in the shirt that I had on
in the other music video.
- I didn't live here.
Oh my. Why am I hanging up clothes?
- Do you remember this?
- Yes.
I will never forget this.
Look at you.
You're trying to be so like sensual.
- Sensual. Yeah.
I'm trying to be super sensual here.
Let's see.
Sort by newest.
- Two months ago?
- Ugh. God.
(both) I like this IG so much better!
- Boring? You wish I did stuff like this?
This is cringe.
- That's what you want?
- This is embarrassing.
- Alright, get the t-shirts.
♪ Alright. ♪
Wait-wait-wait, why were
you a vampire in this one?
Vampire rap.
- This is me and Josh.
- I remember this.
- Have you seen this?
- 2010?
Wait. You knew Josh in 2010?
- Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Yeah, 'cause I met him
at the first VidCon.
I'm wearing an iJustine shirt.
Wait. Josh's part is really good.
♪ You might think that a vampire ♪
♪ In the sun would light on fire ♪
♪ But not if you go buy
books by Stephenie Meyer ♪
- That was like-
(rapping)
- Look at this!
♪ When he's undressed,
just put it on his chest. ♪
- This is incredible.
- Josh's writing's so good.
- This is good.
You should copy this link so--
(screaming)
That transition though!
You're like
- Josh wrote all these.
That was so good.
- You wrote his thing or the whole thing?
- His part.
I'm pretty sure,
wrote my part, too.
- That's incredible.
(rapping)
You know. Oh my god!
Give it up.
(clapping)
I'll applaud.
- Oh my god.
I remember we went to
we went to like the costume store
and then we had to mold
these fake teeth together.
- I remember.
I mean, I don't think I
was here, but I feel like--
- Oh my god.
Breeanne was there because
you guys went to Hawaii
- Yes.
- Your first TMZ picture ever was--
- I got stopped by TMZ
at the airport
and they were like
Hey, Justine Justine Justine.
I was like, "Hi", and I smiled.
Had frickin' fangs on because--
- It was Halloween.
- Halloween.
- You know what's crazy?
I kind of have fangs.
- Me, too.
- Really?
- I feel like mine are very--
- Yours are. Yeah. Little bit more.
I can't watch any more.
- Yeah, make it go away.
- I mean, Josh's part was incredible,
and there's so many more music videos.
I can't even believe that--
- We need part three.
Your hair's long.
- My hair looks good there.
- Wow. Showing some skin.
I feel super uncomfortable on the skin.
- Skin.
God. I miss Call of Duty so much.
- Yeah. Back when it was good.
♪ Johnathan but trash you did. ♪
- Hair's long.
Was that fake?
That's fake hair.
- I think it's fake.
- That's fake hair.
- That's definitely fake.
- This is real.
- Yeah. For real.
- Really long.
- That, not real.
- No. Fake.
- Although, mine's actually
probably almost that long.
Isn't it?
- Yeah. Well this is a nice video.
Is it over yet?
- No, I'm done.
Okay.
Well, guys, that's it.
That is reacting part two.
There's so many more music videos
and cringe-worthy content
that I can react to.
So let me know if you have any favorites
that you'd like us to react to
and I'll see you guys in my next video.
Make sure you check out Jenna's channel.
And if you missed the
first version of this,
I'll put a link also in the description
and a card at the end of this video.
And you can click the little line
and it will be over there.
There's a lot of ways you can find it.
- It's everywhere.
- If you don't find it then
you can't I don't know.
- Yikes.
- See you.
- Bye, guys.
- I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for what I've posted.
- It's too late to apologize
♪ It's too late to apologize. ♪
♪ It's too late ♪
Oh.
(Jenna laughs)
You know the most embarrassing thing is,
is like doing these parodies
and then meeting these
people later in life.
It's super embarrassing.
(contemporary music)
- Yeah.
♪ 'Cause I'll catch you in there. ♪
- I've had a problem once where
I didn't meet Will.i.am or Katy Perry.
- Oh.
(laughs)
(contemporary music)